hello there reject nation I'm Craig
halvah my name is Daisy Howard Dixie
Howard is joining Greg today to watch
the trailer for midsummer saw some are
some mints Omar it's it's a director of
hereditary that's the main appeal behind
this movie you like hereditary I love to
read the best news last year
absolutely glad we're on the same page
yes yeah the Academy this is also from
May 24 one of my favorite you know yeah
yes oh they make big blockbusters and
the huge mainstream anyone could digest
those films easily hey Stacy you're here
for a specific purpose she has to
promote something fine you better send
me news of your boyfriend what she did
so please tell us what's going on
alright so I'm so excited to be helping
plan organize and produce Moulton fast
whoo beloved film critic Leonard Maltin
and his family
Jessie Moulton Alice Moulton the whole
gang is gonna be holding Moulton Fest a
Film Festival at the Egyptian in
Hollywood this is gonna be made 10th
through 12th we are so excited to have
multiple feature films documentaries TV
shows short films hidden gem set Leonard
and Jessie and Alice really really love
and with special guests including Joe
Dante and Holly Payne and Doug Benson to
play the Leonard Maltin game Walton fest
that's epic so weekend badges are on
sale right now you can go to Leonard
Maltin calm slash Maltin Festa get them
today it's after endgame so it's perfect
yes perfect timing let's watch this
nasty all right let's do it one two
three
Christina says that you've got some
special thing planned just bright oh she
looks scared sungai is it cold let's go
challenge that breathing hey Walter
[Music]
oh wait so you don't have a head is it
all connected
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
experience this looks like everything
that I secretly love all right creepy
misshapen faces
you got some very cult-like stuff going
on headless people there's blood I mean
it you know it might be a metaphor for
the female period I don't know
knowing him what's funny is hereditary
had this like subtle element of cult in
there and I wouldn't call it subtle
it ends with like I'm saying it's like
that's not the main hook of it when
you're watching the trailers that's not
the thing that movies leading it's an
element that becomes infused and then in
this movie it's like we're going all
cult movie right here you know so it's
cool to see him like fully embracing
that elements like this feels a lot less
subtle and so Pepper's not headless
feels like it could be right yeah it was
like oh this is the cult that we saw
before right it has a little bit of that
vibe I wonder why it's called somewhere
and you know I kind of makes me flash to
how Jordan Peele had get out and then
had us and you sort of he kinda has a
similar trajectory with the a24
Department right of something like
hereditary which had a big impact or
wasn't a hugely successful film but then
following the trajectory of like I'm
gonna double down now to prove
themselves weird film like now we can go
all weird cuz we gotta we got that
successfully so you guys just do what
you want this film seems like my kind of
movie I love creepy things I love horror
thrillers I love really like disturbing
images scenes a monster inside of Liam
Savage so this has a bunch of great
actors that I love you got GT from the
good place you got Colter no Poulter
Lawrence pew I just saw fighting with my
family and she's Jake if you guys
haven't seen Lady Macbeth please check
out on that that's amazing but she's
amazing in it
I'm glad to see her their leading role
I like the ironic tone behind it I mean
her editor looked beautiful but it felt
like dark and creepy and this it's not
pitched as a cult at first you know it's
pitch more as like a retreat or some
type of spiritual getaway yeah and then
it evolves into this element so I like
how at first it just looks like a
beautiful promo for some type of awesome
like everyone's wearing white like it's
super bright it's sunny
yeah it's summer my guess is that like a
word that he invented some are like
foreign okay I guess is just a word he
made up maybe maybe it's like somewhere
as like Swedish I don't know okay there
you go
this Swedish okay I mean they're all
beautiful at lon so you know shocker
there but all right well I can't wait to
see this movie man this looks like a
really creepy time where all the white
people look evil and all the ethnic
people are who's the guy in here who's
the lead guy the handsome man that guy
Chris Pratt
what's he from I see the brother in sync
Street maybe you bet your arse it is no
William Jack reynor oh yes Hey look at
me yeah good oh yeah I recognize him as
the brother wolf in the Mowgli Andy
Serkis fell oh that's right that's right
recognized him yeah I just saw his voice
and I was like that's who that guy is
and astrum well guys before we wrap this
video up I would like to give a page for
the day shout out to a man named Scuba
Steve I followed this guy on Instagram
because he has this graffiti art page
that is just beautiful it's so illegal
and I highly encourage him to keep doing
and in fact go even further start
spray-painting a lot of these like
satanic symbols that you see in films
like hereditary amidst
because that would actually elevate your
page controversy sells buddy and if you
really want to make some dough you
should start spray painting images
graffiti art of Stacy Howard all over
New York City where you live buddy and I
guarantee you more people will be like I
don't know what that is but this is
awesome this is cool
see yeah I like that plan I like illegal
activity what can I say some white girls
are dangerous huh mm-hmm
no now this videos got a thumbs up yeah
all right guys well thanks for tuning in
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell follow
Stacy Howard on social media and also
make sure to get tickets for the event
that the multi-faceted yes yes that's
what it's called I met Jessie Moulton at
the Mandy premiere she's incredible I'm
a nerd and Alice are all huge film fans
as a family so this is really a film
festival celebrating their legacy and
hidden gems that they love so I'm glad
to do it with them I know that Jessie's
a film fan but her dad uh you know he's
only been a film critic for like 46
years something like that
I mean Leonard Waltons movie guide he
was the first one to do that and he's
been doing it ever since he knows
everybody if you if you listen to their
podcast and just follow them with social
media you're like oh still works there
okay Laura Dern's in their house sure
Amy Adams is chatting them up yeah okay
it's like everybody in the world is ever
gonna read me yeah well you know they
don't interview why speak the truth on
my channel Stacy no go to the mall to
defend today